[Music]
[Applause]
after breaking ethic out of prison hedge
flies them both towards a frontier
settlement in the shadow of the Bradbury
er the great wall that encircles the
nation all the settlers there will soon
gather for the monthly feeding the
people of the wall spend their days
gathering up works of art and literature
from all across the land on feeding day
the furnace box arrived ravenous if they
eat the light stay on and the food gets
delivered if they starve the people do
too edges fuel supply runs out just as
he and ethic reached the outskirts of
town
and they come in for a crash landing
[Music]
luckily everyone is too busy preparing
for the feeding to notice today's
feeding is where ethic can find the
leader of an underground resistance
movement this person knows the location
of the first of three powerful artifacts
the problem is hedge and ethic don't
know the resistance leaders name or
appearance but hedge has gathered the
following information the leader has
green eyes if the leader has red hair
their name has at least one consecutive
double letter if the leader wears
glasses their name has exactly two
vowels otherwise their name has exactly
three vowels there is exactly one person
for whom these are all true as a
fugitive ethic can't sneak into the
crowd without drawing attention to
herself but she can give instructions to
hedge and one tool she has is what
programmers call a conditional that's a
statement of the form if a then B
flowcharts are great illustrations of
how those work this conditional
translates to if a is true carry out
instruction B there are also
conditionals that account for different
possibilities this says if a is true
instruction be otherwise carry out
instructions see so what instructions
does she give hedge so he can find the
resistance leader with a problem like
this it can help to simplify first
what if hedge just has to examine this
one person what information does he need
to collect about her he might ask does
she have green eyes what other questions
should hedge ask to find the resistance
leader and how can he track those
answers
[Music]
it may seem intuitive how you'd approach
this problem as a human but hedg isn't a
human and so the challenge comes from
needing to give him systematic
instructions that will work in any
scenario hedge needs to examine the
settlers one at a time until he
discovers the right person in other
words like with the lock on the prison
cell this is a loop that repeats the
same instructions only this time the
loop will involve a series of questions
in the form of conditionals and will end
as soon as hedge finds his target but
first you'll want to organize your
information each person has a set of
characteristics eye color hair color
glasses and name does this person have
green eyes if so mark a check next to
eye color if not mark an X there if they
have red hair does their name contain a
double letter if so mark a check next to
hair color if they don't have a double
letter mark an X next to hair color
anyone with red hair and no double
letter can't be the resistance leader
but notice that if they have blue hair
hedge will skip this question and go on
to the next one for the last question we
can say if they wear glasses does their
name have exactly two vowels if they
don't have glasses does their name have
exactly three vowels there will be
people in the crowd with glasses and one
vowel or no glasses and two vowels but
they're not who we're looking for so
they'll get exits the resistance leader
must be someone with either check marks
or blanks next to every question blanks
are okay because if someone has blue
hair the rule about red hair doesn't
apply to them you could have hedge ask
every question about every person and
then choose the person with only checks
and blanks but there's a way to save
yourself lots of time as soon as hedge
marks and X have him move on to the next
person you don't need to know the answer
to every question just one X means there
not the target of your search hedge
buzzes through the crowd and within
minutes finds a dealer the resistance
leader and brings her back to ethic
Adila agrees to help them steal the
first artifact the node of power but
under one condition that ethic and hedge
jumps start the revolution by
reprogramming the furnace pots that
terrorized the town and right on cue the
robots descend continue the adventure in
episode 3 of think like a coder or
reboot the adventure with episode 1 and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]